بالبدايه كان يشكو من معامله القوات
الامريكيه الى
وشكم من بعض الامور وتم يعني
[موسيقى]
بداوا يعطوه من طعام
القاده الامريكان المستوى الاول
الموضوع الاخر موضوع نومه كانوا يعني اما
موسيقى صاخبه يعني بطريقه قد تكون مقصوده
او قد تكون هي هاي اخلاقيات الجيش
الامريكي او جزء من افراد ايضا يعني
انهوها من هذا القبيل
طيب بخصوص
اتصالاته في الخارج هل كان يقبل الاتصالات
من العائله لا لا ما قبل رفض يعني لم
يتحدث الى اي فرد عائله لم يتحدث خارج
المعتقل على الاطلاق وكل ما كان وهو في
داخل المعطاه في داخل لم يتحدث الى اي احد
في من عائلته وسطوني حتى يقبل يعني اثناء
المحاكمه ورفض ووسطوني حتى يقابلوه وايضا
رفض بشده
ووسطوني حتى
يعني بعد النطق بالحكم وايضا رفض وطلبوا
من عند الامريكان بيوم يعني قبل الاعدام
بساعات انه يتحدث مع عائلته واذا رفض
لماذا رفض يقول انا ابقى يعني بهذه الرباط
الجيش
والكياسه وما ياثر علي
يعني مجال القوات الامريكيه انه بكره يعني
يقولون ضعف او عائله ضعفت
صحيح كان في عدد منهم يتعاطفون معه
يتاثروا فيه ويعني في علاقه تود بيناتهم
يعني كانوا الجنود واحد الضباط برتبه
ملازم اول تعلقوا بيه كثير حتى مر المرات
انا جالس معه وكان ملازم اول يعني
واصل الامر نقله
الى مكان اخر يعني يغيروه
فدخل عليه هذا الضابط ومع المترجمه وطلب
من عندي ان اكتب القاعده القوات الامريكيه
قلت له هذا سابقه الرئيس كان يعني على
امراه وما اسمع منه قلت لها هذه سابقه راح
يعني تحتسب التاريخي يعني اكتب القائد
الامريكيه اطلب احد ضباط الاحتلال يبقى
قال لي لا الرئيس قال لي لا ابني اكتب
وكان يعني مبتسم اكتب اطلب انه يبقى هو
المسؤول في في
المعتقل بالضبط
كان متعلق به والرئيس ايضا جميل قال لي لا
اطلب اكتب وعلم مسؤوليتي فطلبت بقوه ست
شهور اخرى
ابقوه نعم هو نفسه بالبكاء اجهز بالبكاء
بعد ما خلص خلصت مهمته بده يرجع مسلم
بالبكاء
بالضبط والمره اغتيل الزميل خميس عبيدي
الله يرحمها
في هيئه الدفاع الدفاع واضرب الرئيس لمده
عشرين يوم يتصل الجانب الامريكي قالوا لي
يعني حالته بدات سوء فلازم تجي حتى تقنعه
فهذا الضابط كان يلح عليه قبل لا ادخل انه
ما تطلع من يمه الا تقنعه وبالفعل الباقيه
ايضا ضمني وضم الرئيس